[Music]
so let's go to
natalie in atlanta georgia what's up
natalie how are you doing
hi i'm pretty good how are you good i
love uh
pretty good what's the
what's the uh what's the not pretty part
i can't wait um
well it's unfortunate actually so
i'm a little nervous just because i
haven't told anyone and it's like now i
tell the world so this is just great but
okay before before you say this why did
you pick this this forum to do this
um because i need advice from a
trustworthy source other than google and
i listen to your show and um google is
not a good place i found it's a dark sad
place yes yeah a lot of strange
information but it's this show has been
helpful to me and it's a trustworthy
source so i came here um to get some
advice i appreciate that i'll do the
best i can you'll get what you pay for
how about that
okay great
um so i have made a horrible mistake and
about two months ago
i
found myself an unhealthy relationship
are you married are you married yes i am
married that's the key how long that's
the key problem um we have been married
we're about five years any kids five
years
two children two and four okay
um so i
wanted to do a fitness competition and i
found myself at the gym a lot and there
was a guy there trainer and
basically started
you know helping me out with some
workouts we started talking
and it went too far um
um well
he started talking to me we met for
coffee
and then the part did you sleep with him
we actually ended up sleeping together
yes which is the part that my husband
doesn't know he knows everything
except for that because immediately i
just feared risking
like i was scared of losing everyone and
i was so stupid and i was like just
scared so i immediately lied
and
blocked him from everything i have not
communicated with him since then
and over two months but now i'm like
well great when it was all horrible
i lied and now i don't know if i should
rehash this because things have been
going really well and like we've
really surrounded ourselves with a great
community in church family and
counseling and i have lied so hard about
this one thing yeah among every single
person because in my head i was like
i'll just never ever bring this up
and now i'm like
do to move forward i need to know
whether or not i should tell him
the fact that you're calling tells me
that you know the answer to this
well
google said otherwise i was like maybe i
could get out of this
maybe that's not a good idea um
so you
number one
bravery
bravery thank you for saying this out
loud
go back in when you when you listen to
this call your voice changes after you
say it out loud
okay
take a big deep breath and then drop
your shoulders all the way down
so in your gut what do you think you
should do
um i probably need to tell them
no probably like what what do you need
to do i feel like i need to tell him
because
i feel like if i don't it's just going
to be
preventing us i guess from
truly living honestly
yeah
will this end everything
i
i don't know if it will i don't think it
will i just think it's
gonna make it harder
i don't know what it'll do i mean he is
definitely forgiving and
really understanding but i mean you all
have been in counseling and you've
talked about this
and we've talked about everything and
i've just totally denied
doing anything more than just
communication meeting and all that okay
so
i am just i'm like oh my goodness and
y'all just hooked up one time
yes
it was the hook up and then done
and everything kind of hit the fan like
as in he found out about us
communicating and
and it was like almost like a rescue for
me because it was just not going to go
well from there yeah
that's right
but when everything's starting to look
better i just hate having to rehash all
this
yeah
that's why i've
tried to find a way out i guess what
does your counselor tell you
um well i've actually we have never met
one on one so we're doing it through our
church and it's the couple's counseling
okay and so i still haven't even been
honest with the counselor because i
would have to say it in front of both of
them and i'm like
i don't know if he low-key knows or
something but
because i don't know but
he hasn't really told me anything he
about it because no one knows
so here's what i'll tell you
your husband knows
okay and he doesn't
he might not know that you all slept
together
he might not know that y'all did
anything above what you told him
but he knows there's a gap between the
two of you
yes
and he's going to counseling he's doing
what he thinks he's supposed to be doing
and that gap is getting wider
because as he leans in there's a part of
you that leans out because you know
is that right yep that would be
accurate and so what i'll tell you is
beyond the right thing in the integrity
thing and all that stuff
you're torturing a man that you love
and he doesn't even know it
no i sound like i'm talking on both
sides of my mouth i said he knows but
then he doesn't even know it
he knows there's a gap there and he
doesn't know what it is
right
right i see that
and in some ways it feels better because
he's trying to do everything he can to
jump over that thing and you are too
there's a part of you that's trying to
and there's part of you that's anchored
to still chained to that other thing
right
right
so here's what i'll tell you
i'll tell you you screwed up and you
know that
the season of life y'all are in with a
two-year-old and a four-year-old
um
is hard and you're not the only one
that's ever done that okay
i'm not trying to make it right i'm
trying to say you're not alone
right
and you screwed up
and the measure now is
what's next that's what you can control
yeah
okay so you called me knowing what i'm
gonna say anyway right
yeah i kind of yeah i did
and if you need me to be the person in
your life that tells you that
i think i think your
husband's worth being honest too
i think you're being you're worth not
walking around your life um
dragging
a
load of bricks around with you
okay
and i think you need to be very aware
that this may end everything
yeah he may say i'm out
right because you did this and because i
can't trust you and be filling the blame
or he may need some space and some time
and all those things
um okay it'll be hard
but what i know is that relationships
can't survive big secrets
okay and i know there's all stories on
the internets and all that kind of stuff
um yeah that talk about i didn't say
anything for 90 years that was the best
decision ever made whatever great cool
yeah
you found those right
yeah hoping they would be the right
immediately and i was like oh thank
goodness i'd never have to bring this up
and then it just ate me faded me about
what we really need to do yeah so so uh
role play this with me real quick how
does it work
that's my next question like i
i don't know because there's never a
good time like the kids are sick okay
now he
has an important test or now it's
thanksgiving and like i don't you know i
just i'm like i don't know what to do or
when or how
yeah to bring it up
um
what is uh who what does thanksgiving
look like for you guys
um we would go to his family's house
just
with it's like his family reunion so we
would just go there for the day
um
yeah that would be
intense but um part of me
i don't think
the news will be so shocking i mean it
will be shocking but he won't be like
i never saw this coming because i when
you said that he probably kind of has an
idea already because of the distance or
you know i feel like he'll be like okay
not shocked like he was the first time
he even found any of this
out um
he'll be shocked
yeah because you've probably done a
really damn good job of convincing him
that nothing else happened
yeah that's very true yeah so he's gonna
be shocked he's probably gonna be
shocked as much by your dishonesty as by
what happened
yeah definitely
i'm i'm thinking in my head right now
whether you have this conversation
before or after
right um
part of me thinks the right thing to do
is to not
go pretend with all of his family
yeah
and
to
get a babysitter for the kids and
um
have a conversation with him over the
next couple of days now we're filming
this show the week of thanksgiving and
so it won't come out until december but
we're filming it now and so okay um
the other part of me says what's another
three days what do you think
um
i think i
i just i'm ready to
get it done yeah
um
because
i just the thought of even continuing on
is
really hard i don't want to move i don't
want to like ruin thanksgiving but also
or make that a bad memory
so what i'll tell you this is gonna i'm
gonna sound harsh okay but just know
what i'm saying you've already ruined
thanksgiving
okay
okay and so now it's a matter of
um thanksgiving will be a hard season
for you y'all as a couple for the next
several years
okay and gyms will be a hard
conversation for y'all as a couple for
the next however long you know what i
mean that's that's that's in stone
that's there yeah yeah um
i'm glad to hear you say that my gut
tells me is you get a babysitter today
for the kids okay
and
i'm gonna tell you what i would do off
the top of my head okay
okay i would have a place to stay for me
okay and i would have this conversation
um in a private place if you think for a
second it's gonna go
i mean it sounds like he's a safe guy
he's not gonna he's definitely not okay
um these conversations are often great
with a counselor with somebody else
there okay um if you have a mentor
couple that knows you might want to let
them know that this is happening and
they can be there with you or if you
have full trust and
uh my wife would want me to have this
conversation with her in person
right because then she could kill me and
no one would ever ever find the body
right
right but
every couple's different
okay um but you need to get your kids
out of the home and then have a place to
go and you can offer it
i've got a hotel that i've put a deposit
on and i'm willing to go if you want me
to go spend the night somewhere else
right and he may say no i don't want
that whatever but i think that's a
fair statement just you may need a knife
to cool off
yeah okay and know that
he may say i don't want you coming
around my family during things our
family during thanksgiving um or maybe
we're gonna do thanksgiving or none of
us are going you know everything gets
sideways and that's where you need to be
pretty loose hold everything pretty
loose and be accommodating um because
you're going to blow his world up
yep for a second time right
yes
if you could go back and do this over
again would you do it different what
would you do different
i would have told him the first time he
found out that everything about
everything
for sure let's back up before that
oh
um
well i would not
be talking to somebody like i wasn't
married
or
not
how do i say it like i'm presenting
myself as single or maybe i just wasn't
fully committed to my marriage or
something
like
it it was out of control
yeah
so here we are right
yep so do me a favor natalie um i want
you to let me know how the conversation
goes okay okay
and i'll also tell you one
piece of advice i learned from a crisis
responder that works here too
facts are your friends don't beat around
the bush be very direct and be very
short-winded
okay okay
got it i've been lying to you for the
last two months
i did sleep with this guy and i couldn't
lie to you anymore you're worth more
than that and i love you and i realized
i screwed up and i had to say it period
and that's where the conversation stops
okay okay
not a long drawn-out story of of yeah um
but a
be direct and be incredibly honest
and um
and then go from there okay
okay i will
let me know how that goes
i don't know and uh we'll be thinking
about you okay
okay thank you thank you so much all
right
man